visualizing cultures is a web-based
history program which John dower and I
started in year 2001 John dower is an
eminent historian of modern Japan he won
a Pulitzer Prize in 1999 for his book
embracing defeat I approached John in in
2000 when I knew that OpenCourseWare was
about to go up and I told John that I
thought that this would be a great
platform to to do something new with
history specifically to look at history
not just from text which is what
historians do but from looking at images
visuals that have been produced by by
people from the historical era and to
try to understand what was going on John
surprisingly said yes and so we started
we didn't quite know what you know we
were doing at first but we got very
lucky with our first unit which is
Commodore Matthew Perry's arrival in
Japan in 1853 to open up Japan which had
been essentially isolated closed for 250
years and so you have America in Japan
come classing together in this one
moment in history and from that
explosion of images from both sides you
know Americans depicting the Japanese
and Japanese depicting Imperium his men
and his ships it's just wonderful what's
really interesting is that when you look
at images you get to see things that you
cannot get from written material we
found lots of images where the Japanese
were really curious about various men
and drawing
costumes instruments weapons in my new
detail and with with notes to go along
with them showing just sort of sheer
curiosity who are these people you know
how do they know how do they talk you
saw the same thing on parasite Perry
brought his own artist Heine who was a
26 year old artist trained in Germany in
sort of romantic style and he just fell
in love with Japan yeah you can tell
that in the images he absolutely fell in
love with this beautiful country so much
so that he would sometimes paint himself
into the picture
yeah interacting with the Japanese and
so what you got was this one artist
depicting Japan in a very beautiful very
affectionate way and that's what the
Americans saw of Japan for the first
time this is why even to this day you
know in this country you have this image
of Japan as very beautiful very fun very
beautiful nature and really originates
with highness paintings and so we they
must follow the OCW principle of not
only making it available and open and
free but that everything is licensed
under Creative Commons so that these
images which we got from about 200
museums and be some major museums Boston
MFA Sackler in Washington Hong Kong
British Museum we asked all of them to
sign an agreement that we could present
their images on open on now visualized
in Japan on OpenCourseWare under
Creative Commons and so anyone coming in
and studying or visualizing cultures can
take images and copy them distribute
them alter them into their own material
and use them you know however the
wish one of the populations that we
really wanted to work with or school
teachers and so we did many many
workshops over the years and we trained
face to face around 2,000 teachers this
is we I said we we worked with a
wonderful group out of the universe of
Colorado that specializes in creating
East Asian curriculum and working with
teachers directly to help them to
incorporate them into their classroom
and so they ran this series of workshops
all over the country and as far as I
know it's still being used so high
school teachers university professors
tell us that they're using it on a
regular basis
a couple years ago a university had an
opening for assistant professor in
Japanese history and they had four
finalists and they asked them how do you
teach Japanese history and three the
three of them apparently said they used
visualizing cultures